live musicals are the hottest thing on
TV right now Greece live was just a
rating smash well next up is the first
faith-based musical the passion Michelle
Turner joining Trisha Yearwood in the
recording studio where she's getting
ready to play Mary and that's a big role
but nobody has more faith and mishear
wood than her husband mr. Brooke
did garthe chuckle a little when you
said hey guess what I'm gonna play marry
the mother in Jesus he's been really a
great support in this cuz these sessions
have not been easy for me you know it's
been a little challenging and I'll get
home at night I mean like I don't know I
don't know I don't know if I can do this
and he's like you got this do you get to
sing any of your songs or no Trisha
Yearwood's on yeah no she's a little boy
did not fit aren't you also singing
Whitney song your love is my lamb that's
the first song I sing in this show would
just you know I should have said no Mike
okay you want me to sing a Whitney
Houston song but I tried to just say
this is not about me and this is not
about me trying to do the Whitney lips
because I could not even wanted to it's
about putting myself in that moment and
trying to relay the message to the
people so let's explain what the passion
life is as an 11 million dollar
production about Jesus's final days set
in the streets of New Orleans two hours
live on Fox Palm Sunday the stars will
wear modern clothes Christ will even be
seen in an orange prison jumpsuit after
his arrest Tyler Perry will narrate the
musical that is filled with contemporary
songs so many are asking is it
blasphemous or actually biblically
brilliant a lot of the dialogue is
direct from Scripture and the songs are
so well fit to the story for instance
after Jesus's on the cross Mary sings a
song called broken it's so perfect
I'm broken this is breaking my heart and
it just it makes sense in the moment
this is the crazy thing joint secret the
stairs are very small there's a very
narrow so you have to be very careful
Trisha took the shell down the secret
passageway into the private underground
recording studio where she's preparing
her five songs you are doing the Whitney
song to them yes is that the only thing
you're doing um well we'll see other
performances will include Katy Perry's
unconditionally and Chris Daughtry who
plays Dudus singing imagine dragons
demons with Jencarlos Canela who is cast
as Jesus I think really whatever your
religion whatever your faith whatever
you believe in and to me the message of
Jesus is love one another and so that's
what the takeaway is